we've all heard of the Tinder swindler
but William Alan Jordan is far worse
this man had dozens of wives and fiance
all at the same time lying to them while
he father dozens of children with them
conning them out of millions he
committed so many crimes against these
women including molesting one of their
children and today one of his victims
shares her story on the true Jordy
podcast I thought I was getting to know
him he was researching me he sent a
dozen roses to my work treated me like
an abser princess proposed to me within
2 weeks of meeting him and he sat down
and he said right I've been given
permission to tell you I work for the
official Department Of Central
Intelligence more commonly known as the
CIA he ran across somebody who he had
previously turned as an asset the people
that kind of flew their planes in the
Twin Towers and now knew where his wife
and his kids lived they were either
going to kidnap the kids and rip bits of
them and send them through the post to
us or we had to come up with money I
sold my flat I sold my life insurance I
sold my car I sold my piano I sold
everything it was £98,000 it also turned
out he' taken credit cards out of my
name so so I was actually left with
£56,000 worth of debt and then I got a
phone call from him saying that he'd
been arrested cuz one of his fiances
he'd used her credit card to pay for the
car to get repaired without her
permission so she'd set up a police
sting and then he was also charged with
not registering his address under the
Sex Offenders Act cuz he also turns out
to be a convicted
pedophile
whoa and now a word from our sponsors if
you're looking for the perfect gift to
give yourself this Christmas or one of
your friends then you've got to go to
manscape
and use the code true at checkout for
20% off in free shipping you know why
because they've just released the
performance package 5.0 Ultra which is
the perfect stopping filler give the
gift of good hygiene starting with the
lone Mo 5.0 known as the best ball
trimmer of all time the electric Razor's
Advanced Skin safe technology is a
lifesaver known for reducing Nicks and
cuts on sant's sack you get it
cuz and then a massive balls as well s's
also got a beard so he's a look because
we're also going to give him the beard
hedger Pro kit and it also comes with
the handyman electric face shaver for
all his facial hair needs and while
we're at it we'll throw in the weed
whacka 2.0 nose and ear hair trimmer
along with the manscape boxer shorts and
the nail grooming kit so don't forget to
go to manscape.com and use the code true
that's t e at checkout for 20% off and
free shipping but for now enjoy the
[Music]
video today on the true JY podcast we
have one hell of a story um this book
here by Mary Turner Thompson the
psychopath has inspired this interview
uh what what a what a story what a read
and uh thanks for coming on the show
Mary thanks for having me um they've
just made a documentary about your story
and I think people will naturally kind
of compare it to the closest story we've
heard of something similar would be the
Tinder swindler maybe like you know you
have a man in your life romantically
involved who is a complete and utter con
man uh but this for me is potentially
well worse because multiple children
were created by this man under false
pretenses Millions had been taken from
many women so let's go back to the start
when when you met this man what was your
life like just before he entered it so
we can kind of get a picture of that
okay so as a single mom I had a a
9-month-old baby um so that the
relationship with her dad hadn't worked
out um so I was on my own I was
professional I was busy I was a
professional Busy Body I would literally
go into people's companies and tell them
how to run them better I had my own car
I had my own flat uh own my own place
you know Etc my daughter was going to
nursery and I was going to work
full-time everything was brilliant
everything was fine I was I was very
settled I was very financially secure um
the only thing was that I didn't have a
romantic partner and my friends all said
you know why didn't you try this new
internet dating thing this is in the
year 2000 just come out people were
going oh yes I've met somebody on
interet and what could possibly go wrong
from memory it it you weren't really
into that whole thing and you sort of
left but you left your profile on there
but I mean no I didn't leave it up I I
cancelled the count but they left it up
so I didn't I wasn't even aware it was
there um and then I got this this
message from this guy that was just um
you know said his name was Will Jordan
that he was um mixed race that he was
American that he had a bad B of months
as a child so he couldn't have kids so
as a result he spent his life chasing
his career around the globe and you know
that he was very very into his work but
you know he just you know he he'd never
really had space in his life for romance
you know so he'd had a few relationships
but you know Etc and just just very very
chatty message and I just sort of
messaged back and we got talking and
yeah just as a professional woman
yourself who has a child he he's saying
oh well I can't have kids so you're like
oh well I do have a child and a lot of
the time for single mothers it is hard
meeting meeting men because men very
Territorial and that's not the ideal
scenario for them so this kind of was a
pretty good situation it is I mean it's
ideal really actually when you when your
your priority is a single mom is your
child you know so you want to have
somebody who's going to it's not you
when you're single you're looking for
the bad boys and not everybody this was
my my experience I should say but you're
looking for the you know the thrill the
the you know the fun seeker and
everything else when you become a mom
you're looking for Mr reliable you're
looking for somebody who's going to make
you know that that's going to give your
child a good example of who they should
date someone competent got their [__]
together yeah basically I mean it's it's
like just very different when you when
you just your whole life changes when
you have a kid you know um so yeah I
mean he and he was ticking all those
boxes you know he wasn't he wasn't Mr
exciting you know he was he was just Joe
average but he was he was just solid
that's what for me when looking into
your story hit me more is like you know
you look at the Tinder swindler when
watching that back like a lot of people
are like how did they not say something
something was up whereas this guy was
far more ordinary and therefore far more
dangerous in my opinion far more easier
to go under the radar I mean had he been
super super good-look or super Suave or
anything else no he wouldn't it wouldn't
have worked cuz you would have just gone
and go hang on it's not right you know
but so you get you guys start um getting
on and how long before it went from hey
we've just started dating to oh this is
quite seriousness we met in about 2
weeks um and then but I mean immediately
after we met you know he was talking you
know that that he was he was smitten um
that he was really surprised by the
strength of his feelings things like
that so it was it was all going a little
bit faster than I was comfortable with
not not uncomfortable with but just
pulling me that little bit off balance
um and then is this what they call like
love bombing yeah this is love bombing I
mean he sent he sent a dozen roses to my
work um that's trying hard yeah yeah and
it's like and I hadn't told anyone at
work I was dating any anyone so there
was kind of like that kind of what
what's going on here you know cuz he's
letting every man in that office know
yeah oh she's m now was there any other
things he did other than the Dozen Roses
was there other things he said very
quickly I mean he he used to open doors
he used to walk on the roadside he was
quite oldfashioned in his manners very
kind of Southern American kind of
manners um you know so very s treated me
like an absolute princess you know so
you you just felt you felt like you were
being put on this pedestal
uh and sort of like you know slightly
worshiped um but not not in a kind of
not in a creepy way yeah um and it's
very subtle and it's very yeah it's it
is kind of hard to explain but
just I mean I don't want to don't know
want to jump ahead at all but you know
having had the the conversations with
the other women I know that each one of
us had a different experience he wasn't
just doing a kind of one-size fit it's
all things wow it was like he was being
the perfect man for each of us wow so
there was some of those he was making a
bespoke program he was he was thinking
like psychologically analyzing you going
what does she need and I am going to be
that guy just to you the spoke yes damn
so in in my case I I I will not have
because because my uh my eldest
daughter's dad I will not have a man
yell at me all right because it's that's
that's a deal breaker to me because i'
been there done that not happening again
right so that and he was he never raised
his voice never never sort of you know
if we we would have arguments we would
have deep conversations but they
wouldn't be argu they wouldn't be
shouting right there must have been a
lot of conversation in where he asked so
many questions about you to start off
with well that that was the the initial
stage the two the two weeks we were
talking online I thought I was getting
to know him he was researching me so
it's like whilst whilst I was talking to
him and we were talking about the books
we'd read and I said oh I'd read this
one and he go that's that's the and he
was obviously going off and reading that
book or you know researching it or
whatever um and so he was getting all my
philosophy all my you know my my
politics My Philosophy my ideas my you
know Etc so he he literally was going
okay that that element this element you
know and putting putting together this
chameleon package absolutely that was
the ideal man for me this is why it's so
important to for for women out there to
not give your cards away early on when
you meet a guy because you know if a man
is let's just take it FR out of this if
a man just want to sleep with a woman
yeah he's do like a lot of men do this
same game but just to get to that point
yes um and you're never actually going
to find the right person for you by
telling them what to be so I think as as
women there's a smart move to go don't
tell him you ask the questions don't let
him figure you out because once we
figure a woman out men well we know what
we want don't we not to psychopath men
oh not at all trust me if there's anyone
who's aware of that you're looking at
them damn so it's I mean that the by the
way the theory is that only one in four
Psychopaths a female but actually I
think it's 50/50 absolutely think it's I
think women are much better at hiding it
dude that's that is so true because I
think men are prone and we are going to
go off topics for sure men are prone to
being violent when they're when they're
trying to take someone down and it's
often lashing out not well thought out
women are so much more calculated than
men because they have to be they're not
big and strong so they use what they've
got and they're actually better at it
than men are um so absolutely I agree
with you but and I respect you for
having the ability to say that when
you've had something so bad uh done to
you by a man because it is hard um when
you've been hurt so much
to the thing is I mean I've done 17
years of research in psychopathy and
it's like I don't see myself as having
been hurt by a man I see see myself as
having been hurt by a psychopath very
you know and that's that's you know cuz
otherwise you just tar up all men with
the same brush and I have a son I don't
want that happen um you know sort of
like and I know I know not all men are
are psychopaths it's not it's nonsense
to think so going back to your story
with this guy um so it's it's he's
playing the perfect game yes right now
and um at what point did you feel like
the feelings were completely
reciprocated and you were like yeah this
is this is for me this I know I
romcoms you know it's like all what
we're talking about the love bombing and
everything else is that these romcoms
set us up to believe and I grew up think
I was a romantic grew up believing that
one day you'd meet the one you know you
would just be in love and you know sort
of no matter what happened you would
stick it you know you know um and so
that that's what I was presented with
was this person who was going to look
after me look after my child um that
absolutely adored me that that got on
well with my child you just just just
that kind of
whole package deal was the fire there as
well between you did you feel that there
was that fire chemistry yeah that very
much so um and just yeah just it was it
was literally like something out of a
wrong comp uh deliberately I mean
literally deliberately designed to be
exactly that a lot of women could fall
victim to something like this it's just
how far it goes and how deep it went and
obviously you were really committed so
at what point was marriage and things
like that presented he posed to me
within two weeks of meeting him wow so
uh he stood me up the night before so we
were supposed to be going down to London
to see uh from Iden to go to London to
see The Phantom of the Opera no it
wasn't actually sorry I beg your pardon
we were going down for a party right and
I was going to meet all his work
colleagues so I was very excited to sort
of me meet his work colleagues and uh he
said he was on his way he's on his way
he's on his way and then you know s like
oh we'll get the later flight and you
know etc etc and my daughter was at my
mom's so that we could we could have
this trip away uh and uh this was on
like the 23rd of December or something
so you're meeting him yeah I was I was
waiting at the flat for him to turn up
uh and go away for this for this um um
trip away and uh and he didn't turn up
so I ended up drinking a bottle of wine
going to bed and S you know thinking
I'll go get my no phone call no nothing
well no it just it just he had said I'm
delayed and delayed and delayed and then
just nothing right and I just I just I'm
not putting up with that kind Behavior
you know um so in the morning I was like
that we're done you know it's not
happening I've only been seeing this guy
two weeks you know Etc um and 7:00 in
the morning he turns up and uh and with
a with a white teddy bear and um and I
was standing with my arms crossed and my
legs crossed leaning against the the
cooker actually sort of in the process
of dumping him and just saying this is
not acceptable no you know and he was
like I I'm Ser sorry I was in a um a
basement server area it guy um so I was
in basement server area and I couldn't
get away and you know like there was no
signal and the know whole system crashed
and you know sort of plants were having
real problems and all these kind of
things going I bet you elaborated like
you you laid it on well thick oh yeah
all more details at you as well but
everything was very specific cuz that's
the the more believable it becomes then
cuz he's painting that picture yeah and
I was just and the whole thing as well
was oh you know because I've because I
spent so long in my life working and not
being in relation ship I'm I'm used to
work coming first you know I have to get
used to to switching that around um and
I was still going no no no you know this
is it's not on this not right behavior
um and then he said well I'm really
upset too because I was planning to do
something and I was like do what and he
handed me the teddy bear and around its
neck was a diamond ring and I was just
like what you know it wasn't like I sat
there going oh I lovely Let's Get
Married yeah I was I was just like it
just it it I mean it's it was a seismic
shift in the conversation because he
just proposed to me and I I suddenly I'm
in the middle of dumping him and
suddenly I'm I'm now going I mean it was
an obvious no but at the same time it it
it transcended that from being the
relationship is over to well I'm hurting
your feelings by saying no to you
marrying you so you know obviously when
you somebody stands you up it it it's
because you assume it's because they
don't care they're not interested they
they're they're being he's contradicting
everything you felt in that moment he's
he's showing you I do care yeah and it's
so actions you know and and a proposal
of marriage when he's just stood you up
it's just it just it's so incon your
brain can't can't make that connection
and you know so I obviously said no and
but you know s like said only know each
other two weeks and you know but he was
back in the game was he he was back in
the game yeah yeah a woman being
proposed to is a def moment in her life
and like clearly now we can unpack this
and look back at it and go he was
scrambling and he thought all right
she's going to be pissed I've got the
answer for this but it's a huge thing
and it is powerful and it would have had
an impact on you in that moment to to
forgive him at least I suppose yeah but
it was 7:00 in the morning he already
had the ring so he hadn't that morning
gone out and G all right I'll
sidetracker he had the ring the day
before uhhuh so the whole thing was
actually planned I wonder to what degree
cuz this guy seems like the type you'd
have like 10 rings in a in a you know
what I mean yeah very possibly like this
guy is you just don't know how far the
lengths are and the ring was the right
size by the way wow see he just kind of
go you know so like has he done it so
often um you know yeah he just has to
glance at the woman's finger and go
she's yeah it's like this is a joke man
okay so at that point he's back in the
game and where do we go from there then
so we we carried on dating um probably
about 3 months ago past um he has this
thing of standing me up and you know
sort of like not turning up to things
and I mean things like going out to my
my brothers for dinner um and you know
my brother's finally going to get to
meet him and then suddenly it's last
minute he's been called away for work
and I have to go it's
humiliating to turn up and something he
hasn't you know and it's like to the
point that some of my friends and family
started calling him in my imaginary
boyfriend oh yeah that hurts you know
that was just like you know so it's like
things like when he did send you know
the the the flowers to work and stuff
like that you know I was wondering
whether people was thinking I'm I'm send
myself it was just it was just and that
that's gaslighting love bombing
gaslighting that's how it works you know
because the gas lighting on its own
doesn't work because it just it just
it's just constant praise and everything
else what you have to do is you you
belittle the person you make them feel
like they're going mad you know because
that that that a disconnect with what
they're saying and what they're doing
you know not standing you up but then
asking you to marry them standing them
up and then you know sort of like just
just yeah it's it's it's weird but yeah
so that that that was going on for about
three months I've seen women talk openly
online about how addicted they get to
this sort of behavior and I'm and and
not when there's even an end game just
just by toxic men who throw the hot and
cold game at them and cuz this is why
women like a lot of them find average
Jo's normal guys who are just decent
blocks boring because when they've had
head cases before who you just don't
know what the [__] coming next it's
exciting it is and
unfortunately women like there's a
reason why women like watching soap
operas they you know it's [__]
interesting right and when their own
life becomes one there's a period where
they're like [__] me this is exciting
yeah and it must have been oh yeah I
mean it was but I mean it's at that that
stage it was was it was just kind
of it was getting irritating right the
they standing me up and you know that
that was starting to wear very very thin
um and i i s of I kind of went right I
need to know what's going on here and I
I did a bit of digging around and the
thing was in in 2001 you didn't have
Google you didn't have the kind of
resources you have now um uh so what I
did is I actually looked up company
house cuz I knew he run a company uh and
a company's house it had had this
woman's name and an address in gullen um
as a company secretary for his company
and it was it was an address he had not
mentioned to me um so I thought okay
I'll G is like 45 minutes drive from
Edinburgh I'll go and have a look how
many months in was this roughly about
four months into relationship about 3
months after he proposed her um and uh
yeah and it sort of like so I drove to
this house and he was away in Manchester
at the time he just it had been
announced in the time he' just been
recruited as the the head of it for this
company in Manchester um so that was
legit oh yeah that was legit yeah so
he's doing pretty well there's a whole
other story about that by the way okay
okay we'll get into that but um yeah so
he he yeah he was doing quite well um so
and the company what he said he did for
a living at the time was that he would
hack into people's it systems to see
whether or not they were hackable so
people would pay him to try and see
whether or not they could you know so he
could hack into their system you know so
it was kind of like um um forensic it
guy so I went to gullen and you know had
looked up this house and here is this
huge house on the corner of a really
beautiful and gullen is a pretty rich
town um you know there all golf clubs
and you know stuff like that um and um
and here was this enormous house with
you know his car in the driveway and
children's equipment at the Garden and
you know so like on the roof was all
these antenna and stuff like that um and
and I was sort of going he's bloody
married you know excuse the language you
know he's he's he's married and he's got
kids and but how could that be possible
because he's he can't have kids he's
infertile you know um and this was this
was a bug bear in his life this was
baggage that he took with him it was the
fact that he'd always wanted to have
kids you know that he' know be and he
but he'd known since he was 18 that he
couldn't um and know but this Etc is why
made it perfect that I already had a
child you know all this I mean it' been
it not been nagged but it had been
talked about we didn't talked about
adopting that's that sort of thing so
the fact that he might have kids was
just totally alien at this stage anyway
I went home and I I I I I could have
knocked on the door but I didn't right I
I went home and I texted him I just said
we have to talk this is not good news
right um and so he he came back from
Manchester and and came to the house and
and we sat down we and he said look I've
got something to tell you uh and uh you
know please don't ask any questions
until I finished and I said okay and
then he left the
room right and I'm sitting on the couch
going what and it's like and as far as
I'm concerned you know he's married with
kids he's been lying to me all this time
and but he he left the room and he he
paced up and down in the the hallway
outside the sitting room door talking to
someone on the phone for about 45
minutes and I'm I'm sitting there going
what what answer could there be to this
that is going to come out good you know
um and he came back in and he sat down
and he said right I've been given
permission to tell you um so I work for
the official Department Of Central
Intelligence more commonly known as the
CIA I was a recruited from University uh
I'm not a spy I'm an IT person I work in
a like the guy in the van you know he's
the the one that does the support stuff
that he's a specialist in certain areas
um that he's on condent to the m mod
from the CIA that's why he's working in
Britain
um and and he talked about for about 2
hours telling me all the details of this
thing whilst he's talking my phone is
updating with oci relay you know one of
those old blue Nokia phones and it used
to just have telephone numbers you
didn't get names on it at the time and
it was saying mod relay on it I didn't
even know it could do that at the time
right and and oci relay um and Sim
update and it was just doing beep beep
all the time and I'm kind of keep
looking at my phone going what is what
is going on here
it's just like it was just the most
bizarre conversation um and then he
shows me the the OD c.net website and
you know shows me behind you know the
logins for the the CIA you know you all
the the logos and everything on it um
you know and he said but the the the
main thing he said was you don't have to
believe anything I'm going to say it's
all going to be proved in time so just
just hold off because you'll meet people
you'll see things you'll hear things you
know things will be proved you don't
have to believe anything right now in
regards to the house and the the the
kids toys outside and stuff so that was
a safe house okay so it was it was a it
was it was a team place and the best way
to disgu it disguise it was to have
children's toys I had actually when I
was in the street I'd asked somebody who
owned it and they said oh they don't
know everyone keeps themselves to
themselves around here and he said did
you not notice the antenna on the roof
and I said yeah he said that's all
communication
stuff um you know Etc so it's like you
know and I'm going going okay well he's
most likely still his Mar with children
you know but I will hold off and see if
this evidence comes so it wasn't like I
went oh okay I believe you you know it
was it was the suspension of disbelief
as opposed to me buying into it I think
that the thing that we've glossed over
in this conversation because we can't
reenact it we can't sit and listen to
them but to for someone to sit there and
like log into websites in front of you
and spend 2 hours explaining everything
like you know when you've invested this
reement to this guy and you're in love
with him and you want to believe him and
that's the key here is the love bombing
makes you want to believe him that's
this the secret ingredient all of this
right the fire you know the passion that
you have at this point the memories and
the and and the dreams that you want to
have together you want to believe him
and he's actually coming up with some
pretty um you know as as there's a lot
of men watching this right now that
would sit there go I wish my lies
probably taking notes wish when I got
caught I'd have thought of this level of
[__] but the the point is is he's
obviously a very clever man in regards
to technical stuff and was able to H it
on to you and give you as much and again
as much detail so that it's as
believable as humanly possible so are
you still like sleeping with him and
doing the usual stuff yeah I mean it was
the usual stuff yeah yeah I was I was
still sleeping with him still things
were things were sort of everything else
was fine it was just this standing me up
thing um and you know for I
mean I can't I can't remember what
happened the days after that but it was
very much kind of like okay well I'm
waiting to see where where this evidence
is coming and the next time that he
couldn't come to something I got a phone
call so when instead of standing me up I
got a phone call from from a woman who
said just let you know uh well Jordan's
unable to come um he said you would
understand so just he'll be in touch as
soon as you can so and and he said you
know people will be able to call you now
because you're now in the loop um so
people will be able to cuz you're my
fiance and you know Etc people will be
able to actually include you um so won't
be able to tell you where I am but
they'll be able to say you know so you
won't be left in the Larch so this you
know this woman called me and I was like
oh okay can I ask any questions no but
you know just you know to be in touch uh
and then he got back in touch and so
suddenly I wasn't being just dumped I
was I was actually being included and
then he he started getting sort of money
packet when he was paid in cash for
things he would actually have money
packets which had mod stamped on them um
you know all sorts of other things
happened but it was the it was the
people verifying oh hearing a voice on
the end of the phone is is Rock Solid to
someone you're like all right I'm
getting a fungle from what sounds like a
really professional woman here yeah um
and you know it just begs the question
who the hell was that do you know I I I
thought a long time about that
afterwards and you imagine the scenario
as he goes up to somebody in the street
and says I want to go and get my wife a
birthday
but I'm supposed to be home could you
possibly phone her and just say that
I've been delayed yeah it could been
anyone in the street or you pay someone
or he wouldn't have to he wouldn't have
to he would just you know in a cafe or
anything else he'd be able to turn
around and someone and say listen I just
want to do something as a surprise to my
wife could you possibly ring her and say
or I'm been called away my batter's died
could you phone her um you know Etc it
really it's it's actually that simple
there was one time that I was in a um a
theater and I was sitting there and he
was he he was late coming he said I'll
see you at the theater I'll I'll be
there just leave the ticket for me on
the door uh and then you know sort of
like I'm s sitting there waiting for him
to come through the door and somebody
came up and tapped me on the shoulder
and said um just want to let you know
that he's not coming you know so just uh
he asked me to let you know and you know
and I was just like oh my God I'm
actually meeting someone in person this
time you know and uh and I was kind of
Blown Away by that and but looking back
it's probably the theater manager he
probably found and said could you go and
tell my wife cuz
it's all smoking mirrors it's all you
know it feels very official because he's
painted such an elaborate story so
because he's because he's paintting that
backstory then all these things
happening you know these people
contacting you don't think you know oh
that's some random stranger that he's
asked to do that you know it it's all
fitting in with the narrative that he's
painted um and it's like the the the
thing I think that's the main key about
this as well is there was no end game
visible it wasn't like he was asking me
for money it wasn't like he was
you know some uh drug dealer or
something you know he was clearly a you
know sort of like he's a bit of a nerd
you know it just it there wasn't it
doesn't make any sense what's he gaining
from this you know that that having a
relationship with me is it doesn't seem
like a a good con man's end game does
that make sense yeah because it's a long
con yeah obviously you know um men have
been n to use women for certain things
sex mainly but like to go to these
lengths for for what like and I we'll
get onto that I suppose but um you know
so so so you're still skeptical but
nothing's being verified and sort of uh
what's the next turn in the story for
you in terms of I mean there's more is
there more commitment coming well yeah I
got pregnant there you go then that will
happen that was a surprise well it it
will happen if but it won't if your
husband's infertile well so that was the
biggest the biggest red flag I guess
immediately where you thought this isn't
right I know this isn't right you know
by that by that stage I was so ingrained
in his story I was so hooked into it
that actually I sat down when I found
out I was pregnant I was absolutely
stunned um I genuinely looked through my
diary to see whether or not I had been
to any parties or been anywhere where
somebody might have been able to have
refid me because I was so convinced that
he couldn't possibly father a child
genuinely I don't know I mean it's it's
so hard to explain that I I when I
contacted him to tell him I was utterly
convinced he was going to leave me
because he thought he would have thought
I'd had an affair even though I knew I
hadn't and I was just like I was so
relieved that when I actually told him
he just he just oh my God you know was
that in person yeah so I told him and he
he actually all the blood drain from his
face he was like he he turned you know
he sort of leaned backwards and he he
went against the war he said you know
I've been told that you know it sounds
over dramatic it wasn't quite like that
but um you know he said I've been told
it was like one in a million chance that
it could happen you know and you know
you're just amazing you know you've
managed to conceive a child for me
you've done the one thing that nobody
else could do etc etc you know and you
felt fantastic I I felt amazed because I
I mean I did feel fantastic that he
didn't think I'd had an affair I was I
was really proud of him that he had that
much trust in me um just like you look
back at it now and just go oh but um
yeah I mean his his wife and his Nanny
were both pregnant when he wrote to me
saying that that that he was in fer time
wow you know and it's like this man even
did the nanny oh twice no way two
children with the nanny Jesus okay okay
so so how how long You' been with him by
the time you got pregnant uh that was
about 6 months okay um obviously you're
not you're not thinking that I need to
be protecting myself yeah because the
guy told me he's he's Jaffer he seedless
never I've never heard anyone say that
it's a it's a it's a Newcastle saying
that so you're you're the Wonder Woman
who's managed to give him give him a
child finally and that's I guess a time
for celebration a time to for you guys
to feel like okay this is something
really special we're getting closer more
invested it's more real his his parents
rang me to say how pleased they were to
have their first grandchild you know
that you know they were really they were
just over the moon um but he already had
a a child did they know about the other
children or no yeah they spent Christmas
with the other wife and the five kids so
um yeah oh wow okay okay so I think what
we'll do is we'll we'll go back to the
other people that you find out about
later for now we'll stick on your
journey because um there's a baby on the
way you've already got one child you're
now having another one yes um so we were
we were supposed to get married so um
and we were supposed to be getting
married uh I think it's like July August
or something like that um and I was kind
of like cuz I I was still slightly
oldfashioned going you know if we're
going to have a baby I want to want to
of course tither not you know it's up to
that um and uh so we'd sort of set
everything out send out the invitations
everything was sort wedding bread dress
was bought and Etc um and then taken out
because I was starting to expand um and
uh so it's like that the and and then
sort of like two or 3 weeks before the
the wedding he said I'm being called
away um and he he said I'm I'm going to
be a while you know so so we have to put
it on pause so I had to write out to
everybody and just say wedding's
postponed and Etc and again it was
utterly
humiliating um but because everyone of
course thought he jilted me um and I was
going no I couldn't explain to them what
was going on because I was you know
sworn to secrecy and and I couldn't talk
to anyone about what was happening so I
just had to say no no it's all okay just
he's he's got work so we've just got to
do it another time um so throughout that
kind of next
nine months basically uh I expanded he
came back in December for a weekend um
and the whole time he was away he was
contacting me it was he was in the
Janine area of the Palestinian
territories um which at the time you
know he was he was telling me about what
was going on there I was we were talking
on satellite phone um the basically the
um the the city was surrounded and the
Israeli Army were actually bulldozing
the houses um with people inside so um
was this is what he was telling me so um
I'm I'm not sure how much of it fact or
but um you were obviously really worried
though I was watching it all on the news
I was watching it expecting to see my
partner there um and you know he he was
stuck in basically a situation he
couldn't get out of he was dropped in
there and he couldn't get out so you
know he was there for for months on end
so I gave birth um um and he was still
saying I'm I'm should be with I'll be
I'll be there I'll be there I'll be
there um but he just never turned up and
when he did finally arrive home um his
daughter was now so two months old um
and uh he he arrived home and his his
feet were in a horrendous State they
were all cracked and black and blue and
stuff um and uh basically said he he
hadn't been able to take his socks and
shoes off for for 3 months um and when
he came back he actually had to have a
socks pretty much surgically removed
because he just he hadn't been able to
take them off so I mean and I and he was
really thin and he was really kind of
gray looking he's like a method doctor
this guy isn't he yeah he really takes
this [__] like to the next level oh yeah
oh yeah totally so he'd been like doing
all of this to himself knowing when I
get to see her this story needs to line
up so I need
physical issues G wrong with me to Make
Her Say oh he's not in a good way it's
been hard for this whereas in reality
I'm assuming he's with this other family
just on a diet and I'm wearing boots two
sizes too small for him for 3 weeks yeah
so and how many months in total had he
been away by the time you'd seen him
again so he was away about nine months
so cuz I was about two or three months
pregnant when he left and and and I saw
him once when I was about six months
pregnant for a weekend and then he came
back when she was about 2 months old
that must have been really hard for you
going through a whole pregnancy like
let's put that to one side what what
you're being lied to just even doing
that being a woman who's pregnant on her
own with a 2-year-old daughter dude I
like that is hard to it's not easy but
it was like dating Superman it was like
complaining about Superman not coming
back for dinner because he's off saving
the world you felt so selfish
complaining about it not no not every
woman's like this you see so like
there's a lot of good men out there who
need time to go to work most of my mates
are offshore uhhuh and they still get
[__] off their woman all the time right
so like you were very much putting him
first yeah constantly there to think
that but it wasn't I mean it's not just
him though because it's like what he was
telling me he was doing was something
that's that's helping helping people yes
does that make sense so it's like and
you're seeing it on the news so it's
real yeah and I'm seeing seeing dead
children in the street I'm seeing people
being you know people's lives and homes
being literally torn out and and I'm
sitting there going well I'm sitting
here pregnant and alone mhm you know
it's it's like how can I complain about
that you know when there are people
dying it just it that didn't it just
felt wrong it just felt so selfish so I
you just swallow it you just don't you
don't go and I'm not going to do you
think it was to do with the pregnancy
that you didn't want to have to deal
with that or I don't know actually cuz I
it's it's very possible there were just
other things going on for him at the
time yeah you know he was just he was
just s of kind of I mean I I think in in
terms of as a
psychopath uh he wants to control people
he wants to and actually having the
girlfriends pregnant and sleep deprived
or having already had his child you more
attached to him so now this is the
father of your child you've got to then
interact with them regardless even if
you if even if you're not in a
relationship with them anymore you still
have to interact with them and therefore
you are still in part under their
control he's got you he's got you once
he's got you pregnant I've completed the
game then I've got I've literally
implanted my Ed in you so therefore you
belong to me on some level yeah like not
even belong it's just a play thing the
to a psychopath that that it's not it's
not like attachment yeah so there there
are some I I know where you're coming
from because there are some guys who
kind of feel like territorial yes but
it's not like that it's not with a with
a psychopath it's not that that'd be
more
narcissistic right but with a psychopath
it's more like a Sims game wow right so
it's more like I'm making this character
do this and I'm making making this
character do that you know and if if
that character dies it's like oh okay
all right well go on to this one you
know it's it's like it doesn't matter at
all so it's not like a possession or
anything it's not you you it's more like
an ant farm that's such a great
description because for for normal
people uh I I would never think about
using someone in such a way like that as
as entertainment so to speak um so yeah
that is is mind-blowing and when he
comes back into your life uh like you
said in a situation where you sleep
deprived you've had to do all of this on
your own raising a child having a child
now he's finally there did you feel like
you became a unit again well yeah we did
I mean when he first came back well came
back came back from Oxford but came back
from Janine he he wanted out of the CIA
so he now wanted to be a civilian and
not be part of this so um we then went
through the whole process of trying to
get him work and he got work in a big IT
company he was earning a lot of of money
he was learning about £10,000 a month um
which is a lot of money to me it's a lot
money especially back then remember yeah
so it's like and and he was he was you
know suddenly now we had the high life
we had you know we were able to uh
although I own Mo flat was a two-bedroom
flat so we ended up renting a house so
that we could have the rooms that's when
disaster struck so disaster struck in
the form of when he was working for the
big software company because he was no
longer protected um the in intelligence
Services he ran across somebody this is
the story told me he ran across somebody
who he had previously um researched and
uh turned as an asset um who was part of
kind of a a unsavory group should
conspiracy type thing um more like the
people that kind of flew the planes in
the Twin Towers kind of thing all right
um so and because he was no longer
protected he was using his real name and
his real passport and everything
everything else this person now knew who
he was and had looked up in his details
on the the HR stuff and in this company
and now knew where his wife and his kids
lived and had said to him that they were
going to extract Revenge from him and
they were either going to kidnap the
kids and rip bits of them and send them
through the post to us or we had to come
up with money to protect them and you
know and he had no protection from
anybody because he was no longer cuz he
was out you know so I'm trying to um and
I'm sure you might be able to help that
with this I'm trying to sort of reason
okay he's making £10,000 a month here
which is great money mhm he now comes to
you with the story that well we need
money to pay these people off yeah I'm
trying to understand where the real need
for money was if he's making all this
money and what what what is the real
purpose behind all there's no real
purpose behind it the the thing that
drives psychopath is money sex and power
it's actually the thing the real driver
the real of a psychopath is boredom so
nothing nothing engages them so him
going to work every day and having the
love and support of a wife saying as
children which for a normal man would me
10 grand a month every it's the dream
actually it's actually the dream that
every man wants in my opinion so for him
though [__] this yeah I need to stir
some [__] up yes yeah that's wild man
exactly what it is yeah and it's like
and it's also it's also not about the
money right what it's about is about how
much measure of control he has over
another human being because that is the
real game yeah you know that the money
is just the measure of control you know
when when people don't have money you'll
use something else um so he wants to
judge the how how how much chaos can I
inflict on this situation and her still
be here and I'm going to measure that in
how much money she can find in this
scenario yeah just for how much can I
what what can I make her do to keep her
kids
safe what what will she do to keep her
kids safe how far will she go and also
not just for our kids but for for him
yeah yeah he's the one benefiting in
this fake scenario so so so how far did
you go I've got I've got a great example
when we're talking about how psychopath
function I'll back to that in a second
but the the thing that's still pisses me
off right big time and I know why it
pisses me off and it's CU because of my
reaction to not anything else and it's a
really simple thing but it's a really
really good example about how
Psychopaths function right is that he
told me once oh I'm I'm I'm back in
Edinburgh and you know can you come and
pick me up uh and I had so Robin was
about three years old and ay was just a
baby in in the you know in the uh car
seat um and so I said yeah sure and I I
to went drove over to Edinburgh George
Street sat on the thing text him and
said I'm I'm here come on you know and
he all brilliant I'm on my way down and
I sat there there singing songs with my
daughter luckily a was asleep um but
singing songs with my three-year-old
daughter and 10 minutes go by and I've
texted him again and going where are you
you know we're still waiting and he go
oh sorry I was caught on the stairs
somebody just asked me to do something
um you know I I'll not be long all right
so another 10 minutes goes by and I'm
texting him again saying where are you
you know this is getting ridiculous um
and he's going oh sorry the person asked
me to do something you know it's not
going to take me long etc etc this one
on for two hours hours wow 2 hours I sat
there after 2 hours he stopped texting
me back so I sat there for a little
while longer and then just went
home just drove off right what annoys me
about it is a he wasn't in Eden he was
in Oxford at the time so he wasn't even
there he just wanted to see how long he
can make me
wait just to see how long and in this
case time is the measuring stick not
money but yeah so it's like but what
annoys me about it is I didn't give up
he did he got bored of the
game so I actually stayed so long that
he kind of went you know done with that
and just went off and had tea with his
wife or whatever and left me still
sitting there still texting him do you
know do you know how you're beating
yourself up about that in that that's
what this is you're angry at yourself
cuz you feel like I've been a mug it but
like a good man would deserve that you
know do you know do you know what like I
don't I don't mean because a good man
wouldn't put you through that but like
when I hear stories of women like this I
always think to myself like yeah but you
see that love that you had that
dedication and
devotion when when women like that meet
a good man it's a match made in heaven
because you're both giving and it's a
competition of who can give the most
then not taking and giving why didn't I
meet someone like
that I mean yeah it is hard to meet good
people like that's that's true but like
unfortunately I think that the great
people often end up with the takers yeah
like well that's that's that that's
actually there's a they target them they
see them Psychopaths particularly Target
empaths one of the things I was that my
book I was researching I was really
quite fascinated by is I know there's a
spectrum of psychopathy so about 1% of
society is Psychopaths full-blown out
not Psychopaths up to 15% of the society
are on that spect
just a scary thought that really makes
sense yeah yeah but it's like what I'd
never realized before I started writing
the book is actually there's another the
other end of the spectrum you've got
people that are so empathic they can't
actually function um and you've got you
know up to 15% of people are on that
that upper Spectrum I've seen them as
well and it's so so I can't watch things
like jackass right without feeling
physical pain yeah when I watch it
because it's like I I empathize so much
with people I actually feel that
physical pain there's actually there
there's two points in your brain can't
do this with the headphones on but
there's two points in your brain that
that's behind your ears and and just on
the top of your head that if I snaap my
finger and just went crack in front of
you your eyes would crinkle you you kind
of like winse backwards because it's
like two hot needles going into your
brain you feel physical pain on somebody
else's pain right and the more empathic
you are the more physical pain you
actually feel so I if I see someone
hurting hurting like a kid falling over
and scraping their knee my knee hurts
you know I S of like and I I I just
can't watch those things with people my
kids can watch them and laugh their
heads off they think it's brilliant and
I just kind of I just wince and it's
like so Psychopaths don't have that at
all so they don't have any kind of
response when somebody hurts themselves
they don't feel anything they just kind
of you know if they see a car crash
they'll look at it and go ooh how are
people reacting so they can learn from
it and this is why often you know you
hear with them as kids torturing animals
stuff like that things that ordinary
people who are just in the middle not
great people necessarily but not
horrible even they couldn't handle the
thought of you know they yeah they and
they are just so soulless and
emotionless it is bizarre but I actually
really like the point you made about the
people who are too empathetic almost
like uh having met some of them those
people who are too nice for their own
good too soft um and it's crippling
having someone like that with obviously
one of these Cycles it's like food you
know um and unfortunately it feels like
that was a bit like what you became in
that scenario um so so yeah um going
going back sorry to this point where
he's going we need the money what are
you going to do what did you do
everything everything I could I sold my
flat I sold my life insurance I sold my
car I sold my piano I sold everything um
and it wasn't like it happened overnight
it was it was like a a sharks Feeding
Frenzy over about 9 months
so uh I mean for instance initially it
wasn't it was like 10 grand so okay how
can I get 10 grand okay well you know I
borrowed it off my my mom for that and
then um okay so when you say it was like
10 grand do you mean he was putting
different numbers at you going right now
we need this then we need that yeah yeah
and it's so it start it wasn't like they
said oh we're going to need like this
much money up front it was just like
this this is what they're needing and
they need more and they need more they
need more they need more and it's it's I
I went into complete panic mode um you
know sort of the fight or flight thing I
was in both fight and flight and I was
just like the the only thing I could see
at the time was my children were in
danger um and so I borrowed as much
money I could when I when I realized I
couldn't borrow anymore I sold my flat
paid off those debts then had more money
in the bank and thought well at least
I've got this money you know Etc um and
that went that just went you know bit by
bit and then to to him to him all told
it was £98,000
um and eventually I couldn't even pay
the rent I couldn't feed my kids I all
the money he was earning his 10,000 a
month that we still earning was going to
this debt to going to these people so he
wasn't bringing anything in either
though he still earning he wasn't
bringing anything in and were you still
living in the rented uh so I mean my my
head at the time my head was sort of
thinking well he's earning 10 grand a
month so once we get this sorted you
know we're going to be back on our feet
really quickly you know I was earning as
well it wasn't like I was sitting doing
nothing you know I was I was working as
a consultant at the time as well so I
had a fairly okay income as well um so
it wasn't like it was just or you know
anyway but um so you know in my head it
was like if we can just get past this if
we can just hold on if we can just stay
alive basically until you know until
this is done um until they they stop I
don't know what I thought was going to
stop them but you know I think in my
head I knew it was going to be when I
had nothing left um yeah but when you
when you're operating out of love which
is what you were coming from you're
coming from a place of love you don't
want to quit do you like cuz you got
babies to look after so the the the
option of quitting when you have
children is is not an option is it it
doesn't it doesn't even there was no way
of quitting you know it wasn't like if I
said right well I'm no longer in a
relationship with him that we wouldn't
be in danger because as far as as far as
I was concerned he was he was the one
that was keeping us safe he was keeping
them away from us all right and it's
like if I just said all right you buger
off then we're just facing these people
on our own if that makes any sense I
mean I I was so brainwashed that I just
the only person I thought I could trust
with him I couldn't tell anyone else
what was going on in my life uh to
everybody else I had a smile on my face
everything was good you know it's was
fine everything else not a single other
person knew nobody knew and when you're
transferring the money is it are you
wiring it or is a cash cash I mean a lot
well some of it was going into an
account that he had that that I was so
so some of it was paying into account I
mean towards the end it was like £50
here and there you know because it was
like what could I scrape together it was
no longer like 10,000 here and there it
was it was it was £50 can you give me
£50 for petrol and I can at least get to
this place um you know Etc I mean it was
literally squeezing that lemon dry um
and I couldn't I mean I hadn't paid the
rent in 3 months and you know sort of
like the he he constantly said oh I've
paid it I don't know why they're asking
for it I've paid it I've paid it you
know um and I just said to
them it's not happening um so you know
with um by this time by the way I was
pregnant again um and so the whole way
through my pregnancy I was living in
this absolutely horrendous stress State
um I mean he got me a taser so I was uh
going around the house every night I
would wake up hearing noises in the
house you know he'd be away he'd be away
working this this this big software
company and you know so I'd be on my own
in the house with the kids and every
night in my head I would see these
shadowy figures around every door and I
would hear noise and I would get up and
I would search the house and and with
this taser in my hand you know just
utterly terrified of what he had you in
a in a manic State almost totally and it
was utterly terrifying I mean it was
horrendous and at the same time no money
so I would be looking down the backs of
sofas and stuff like that to see if I
could get enough money to get some milk
so I could at least me the kids some
porch
and I I mean sort of not my finest hour
but I would actually go around my mom's
house or friends houses when I knew they
would be cooking their tea for their
kids so that they would go oh yeah we
want Dr some you know yeah you know just
to make sure the kids got a good meal I
mean it was honestly it was it was a
sharks Feeding Frenzy it was just like
it was horrendous just I hate hearing
that for you because uh you know the
fact that your CH like as a mother the
the thing that you're going to be rating
yourself on is am I doing a good job for
my children first and foremost that's
the first thing you're judging your
self-esteem on and and you are trying
but you're so um as you say brainwashed
by this guy and and the question is is
where is all this money going in reality
like do we have any idea or okay we'll
get at that point um so you're you're
pregnant again and what point at this in
terms of timeline how long have you
known him now by the time you're
pregnant again and this is happening by
this stage uh I was sort of moving out
the the house I was years since you met
him now roughly so yeah that was that
was sort of four four and a half well I
met him in 2000 so yeah so four and a
half years I'd say um and uh we had um I
had to move out the house so I had to
pack the house up um put everything in
storage and I moved in with my mom and
dad and sort of like that that was fun
aged you know 39 saying to my mom and
dad you know I have nowhere to go will
you take me in um can you just re
explain that sorry cuz that was a bit
confusing for me I couldn't pay the rent
so I couldn't pay the rent on the house
I had nothing left I had no money I had
I had my income I had my my money coming
in from my income so but I didn't it
wasn't enough to pay the rent on my own
um and so I said to my parents you know
can can you put us up you know until I
find somewhere else and they say why
because you've got a fell and he's
earning good money by by that stage you
know he' actually sat them down and told
them what he did for a living and that
you know things were a bit fraud at the
moment but all going to be sorted so um
so they're in on it as well yeah so yeah
they were sucked in as well um my
brother also who is very very CNY guy um
Nobody's Fool um and initially was very
distrustful of of will um and uh he got
him very very drunk so deliberately so
one one night when we were over uh I
think I was pregnant at the time so I
wasn't drinking but he I think between
the two of them they drank about six
bottles of wine I mean they were abs
stocious um and because because will
then had all had now included my family
in the in the the story not it not too
much detail but just there was more to
this and that he worked for intelligence
Services um and so my brother got him
was quizzing him when drunk and you know
he was telling all sorts of CIA secrets
about who killed JFK and I mean honestly
everything in absolute character all the
way through to the point that he
actually got alcohol poisoning and he
spent the night on the bathroom floor um
and I went home to the kids and but he
was still sticking to his story so after
that my brother believed him as well so
in throughout this time were there any
periods where he slipped up a bit like
cuz cuz although these stories are
far-fetched they're consistent yeah so
I'm I'm wondering were there any little
mistakes that you look back on you went
ah you [__] up there and I should have
seen it uh yeah I hate the word should
but yes um or could should is a shaming
word you know um but yeah there were
certainly times I could have seen it and
um for instance there was one point
where he turned around and he said uh we
were having a family event and and and
he was there and he came up to me and he
said um I'm just I'm a bit uncomfortable
your sister just made a pass at me right
and I just killed myself laughing I just
absolutely decked myself and went no she
didn't and cuz I know my sister well
enough to know that there's no way she
would ever do that right and it's that
that's the kind of relationship we have
and he just kind of went oh oh right I
must got it wrong and I now know what he
was doing was trying to drive a wedge
between me and my family but that's
something he never managed to do cuz he
wanted you isolated yes so he had to he
that's why he had to include my family
because he couldn't isolate me from them
so he did initially so in the first
stages of it it was just me and him but
then you know sort of by this stage when
I was moving in with my you know back in
with my parents he had to start making
sure cuz they were getting you know what
the heck's going on um as I'd managed to
hide everything until then but you know
that that stage he he had to actually
include them but yeah so I mean that was
one stage there was also um he told us
that he'd been he'd lived in Japan for a
couple of years and that he spoke fluent
Japanese now this was before he found
out that my sister is married to a
Japanese man and and lives in Japan she
actually she's an international sculptor
uh and uh so she she you know every time
she was coming home and and stuff he he
would vanish for work and uh and so
she'd never met him and she's a very
she's a very strong skeptic about
anything you know uh so uh she she was
really wanting to meet him and was
absolutely determined when she did she
was going to see if he did speak
Japanese you know um so finally I don't
know why I think in my head I knew he
was avoiding her so I I hadn't told him
that she was home uh and we went around
for lunch my parents and they were all
there and and my sister was there and uh
and she asked him something in Japanese
we're all sitting around the table you
know sort of like ay his his first first
daughter uh is sitting in a high chair
just opposite him and uh and she she
asked him something very simple like
what was the weather like in Japan when
you were there in Japanese right but it
was something he would he wouldn't be
able to Bluff his way out of and uh she
she we had a conversation about it me
and my sister afterwards because she
left that day thinking that there wasn't
anything wrong right but he never
answered the question all right and we
realized that was the time that A's high
chair fell over
oh my God he kicked his own baby
daughter's high chair over to avoid
answering the
question so by the time every all the
chaos has stopped and everything else
she knows she's asked her question but
she never got an answer but she doesn't
even think about it because something
more dramatic
happened
yeah opportunistic to the fullest extent
no matter what happened he'll do
anything right yeah yeah but it's you
got to remember he doesn't care about
his children any more than he cares
about the women they're they're just
porns they're just play things they're
just Sims was a really good description
of that yeah yeah um all right so the
second baby is now so yeah so Zach my
second second my my boy my son was born
I couldn't remember the word for it
there uh was born on the 1st of April
2005 and just I mean I moved in my
parents just at that time basically so
we were living I mean my parents
brilliant I mean they had they had a
decent sized house so they had two spare
rooms so me and my son were in one room
and the daughters my two daughters in
the other room um and and we lived there
for about 3 or 4 months were you still
sending him money throughout that period
I was Absolut brassic about that stage I
had nothing left all right so you were
saying we've got nothing just he he did
ask for money and he said you know we
need we need this we have to have this
and this is the reason why and he gave
me much more detail about the the
dangers and everything else and I I
literally just wrote back I still got
the email wrote back to him going Bring
it on I have nothing I can't do it and
he said can you borrow money off your
family and I was like no cuz I'd already
I'd already kind of like I wasn't going
to I I knew I'd lost everything in that
stage and I wasn't going to do the same
to my family I wasn't you know it's like
it was actually that kind
of that moment of right you know if
they're coming they're coming you know
there's no more I can do you know and
I'm not going to I was I just I had
enough empathy from my my family not to
drag them down with me but he wanted
that oh yeah wow there's just
relentlessness here isn't there there's
just nothing there's nothing he won't do
and uh and and so so the game is sort of
over at this point I'm assuming did he
accept that or not no I think well yes
or no I mean as in money the money game
the money game had ended so that you
said he changed to a different game yeah
okay so it's like me at that time I was
kind of um I I was sort of kind of I
think my logical rational brain was kind
of going there is no reason now there's
no money left there's no reason for them
to actually kidnap the kids there's no
reason for them to come and hurt me or
the kids but so they're probably going
to leave us alone now because as long as
they know there is nothing you know Etc
that the the I just I figured that was
it was at least the game that game was
over their game the the unsavory game
was over um and uh
so yeah and he was like okay and and
just I'll deal with it and so he kind of
disappeared for a while and I didn't
know what was going on but I had a baby
son to deal with and you know Etc so I
was just I just tried to put one foot in
front of the other you know that
pregnancy was he present for much of
that or no yeah he was he was back and
forth he was back and forth all the time
and he didn't spend like weeks with us
he would spend a few days with us and a
few days away and then she you know Etc
so um it was always very SP ER adic you
know when we'd see him um but I mean he
said he was like being you know he was
basically sort of like jumping all over
the place trying to he lost the job with
the um the software company um he ended
up getting a job at the um Deputy Prime
Minister's office uh Deputy Prime
Minister John Prescott wow um and he was
working there this is true this is true
yeah I mean I I went into his offices I
I went my security they waved at him you
know we went to Saw's office and you
know apparently so did a few others but
um you know it just so yeah he did
actually work as work in the office but
it was it was a little bit more evidence
that he' got a new contract he was you
know as intelligence services but within
this office you know uh he wasn't he was
just an IT guy but and then I got um uh
a phone call from him saying that he'd
been
arrested um and he he he was driving a
Mercedes car which I I was paying for
was coming out of um uh out of the
business account right so we set we set
up a business together um and so it was
coming out of that account which of
course the only money going into it was
my my money so he was actually arrested
at the car dealership getting the car
repaired um and turns out that he was
the reason he was arrested is because
one of his
fiances he'd used her credit card to pay
for the car to get repaired um without
her permission so she'd set up a police
thing and uh he was arrested at the car
um and they searched the car and they
said um they found papers pertaining to
his other wife in the car and then they
looked at the car ownership and they
said hang on a minute who's this and
they rang me and said where's your car
and I said it's my my husband's driving
it you know and they said oh thank you
very much and that was it and then I got
a phone call from will saying angry
first time ever I've ever heard him
angry saying what have you done and I
was like they asked where the car was I
told them you know you know no no you
don't know what you've done you've
destroyed everything you know and uh
yeah so it turned out of course because
they had the papers his other wife in
the car they charged him in
bigamy um no because it's like I said my
husband's driving it so they knew that
that he was married to two women so he
[__] up by using the credit card of
The Other Woman yeah not not his other
wife one of his fiances so in 2005 he he
didn't just have two wives he had five
fiance as
well so uh and uh so yeah so basically
this police sting they found the taser
in the car as well cuz when I went moved
into my parents house I knew a taser was
illegal um and uh but I did actually
report to the police and said I had this
taser you know sort of like I need to
hold my hands up to this and the police
police I talk to said did did you buy it
and he said no he did and did you bring
it no he brought it in the house and
what did you do with you know sort of
like did you take it out of the house I
said no when we moved out I he took it
away with him I said it was never yours
um so it's I was but I was I was glad
that I did hold my hands up to that
because it's like I I thought that that
was probably a criminal act but it
wasn't mine so so he he was charged with
bigamy so bigamy Firearms cuz he had the
taser in the car um because I'd made him
take it away with him when I moved into
my parents he was charged with um the
fraud of his fiance about £5,000 and the
one of the fian and then he was also
charged with not registering his address
under the Sex Offenders Act because he
also turns out to be a convicted
pedophile
whoa what I've done a lot of interviews
love it's one of the most
shocking that is that is shocking it is
it just it's quite an extraordinary
story isn't it it's just like I mean the
the the pedophile side of things one of
the that there's do you know that that
there's a test called the psychopath
checklist revised pclr devised by Dr
Robert hair um who is the leading expert
World leading expert on psychopathy and
it's it's a 20 question checklist and
it's like the first it's a statement and
you you it's done by a professional and
a criminal facility right so um but the
statement for instance the first one is
grandy of sense of self-worth and it's
like is that zero so that person have
zero or is it one or is it two so are
they definitely bit of it or are they
nothing right and one of one of the
criteria so it's juvenal delinquency you
know grandio sense of selfworth um you
know many many marital relationships uh
you know Etc and it goes through that
and one of the things is Criminal
versatility and it's like a lot of
criminals will con will will be a thief
you know or be a rapist or be a murderer
um Psychopaths will do everything they
will do different things all over the
place um and I think with the particular
case um it was and I have to be very
careful to make sure we don't identify
the victim in this case particularly um
there was one victim specifically one
one specific specifically yes and it was
the child of one of his um Partners um
and she was between the age of nine and
13 so it was convictions against a girl
under the age of 13 you said when it
when you said it was the child of a
partner without going into specific not
one of his wasn't his child stepchild or
something um but uh uh I mean not a
stepchild but a child or one of his
Partners um but yeah so it's and I think
personally
that in his mind remember no guilt No
Remorse no you know empathy etc for
anybody I think the mother and daughter
were close and I think that he in his
mind was by having an affair with the
daughter he was alienating the mother
from the daughters like what he tried to
do to you with your sister right it's to
divide and conquer yeah but it's like
because because he doesn't have that
kind of moral compass that tells him I
mean he knows it's wrong but I think it
was just a matter of you know doesn't
care doesn't care so and going back to
the biger me uh charge at that point did
it all come crumbling down in the sense
of all you got notified what had been
going on or was that left for you guys
to connect the dots yourselves no
actually it it's it's strange isn't it
but the police actually did say to him
he had to tell me what was going on
because otherwise they would um because
he told me at the time he said you know
sort of the biger me well the other wife
wasn't another wife she was an asset um
and didn't I remember I'd spoken to her
and I I kind of like vaguely remembered
speaking to her uh at one point and
there's a whole another level of things
there is that actually there there were
times when he would come home and we
would have you know we would have um PCO
and pizza or whatever and you know so
like we'd have a few glasses or whatever
and I I don't usually get so drunk cuz I
don't remember things uh and I thought
it was just because when I was with my
husband I was relaxed and I would wake
up in the morning and I wouldn't
remember things all right and sometimes
he would tell me things had happened and
i' I'd kind of just take it on board
that that's that has happened that's
what happened so he had told me that I'd
spoken to this woman before uh and I
hadn't just I he it's just a kind of a
setup thing he's reallying ahead then so
yeah so I I believed I had spoken to
this woman that she had told me that she
was an asset um and so the bigamy thing
wasn't huge to me because it's like I I
knew that that was somebody who he had
used to be involved with um
professionally right um to allow him to
come and stay in the country um and then
there was the you know so like so he was
he was breaking down the the the
criminal sheet instead of saying that
there's this there's this but I'm
sitting there going all right this is
sexual assault charge here that I need
to know about oh sorry sorry can can I
just backtrack just so that people
understand are you now in uh a police
situation with him or are you at home
with him where no no I was at home so so
I I got that call from the police first
of all then I got a call from him and
then things went quiet he disappeared
for weeks and then suddenly he got back
in touch and says I need to tell you
what I've been charged with because if I
don't then the police are going to call
you in fact he actually said the police
are going to call you but I want to tell
you first um and so the good guy again
yeah so but what he did is he broke down
all the the charges so the bigam me was
his asset that's fine the fiance thing
he's he said you know that's just a
misunderstanding um the the the fraud
was just a misunderstanding he didn't
say it was fiance um that the taser well
I knew what the taser was but then this
this um the sex offenders register um
was the the sticking point that he had
to explain to me about and what he said
is that the person involved the the girl
involved in this in that case actually
signed a piece of paper saying that he
had um molestor so that he could go into
a sex offenders prison and gather some
information from a particularly nasty
group so they could bring down a
pedophile ring right and here's me after
all this time I've lost everything I've
had two children with this man and I
kind of go it's either or now it's like
jumping the Grand Canyon in in two
bounds you can't do it you have to be on
this side or that side that's it and
it's like my brain could not comprehend
that this man could be a pedophile could
not comprehend it just could not compute
um but at the same time having been a
victim of childhood sex boost myself
even worse I'm just sitting there going
absolutely stunned by this and and he
said you know the just hold off don't
say anything to the police about it but
just know hold off we'll talk afterwards
and I'm going to get you to talk to the
victim in this case so she can verify to
you never happened so I'm kind of going
right I speak to the police always does
this doesn't he don't make a decision
now give me time just wait yeah and um
so told to the Poli police please tell
me you know what you know what was going
on did you was I aware of this and I was
going no he just told me I'm in shock
which was true anyway so I had to go and
see the social work department because
you know they they had to verify that if
he's you know if he's going to come back
into the house then they have to take my
children
away and so I'm I'm sort of now dealing
with social work I'm dealing with police
I'm dealing with him I still believe cuz
I can't get my head around the fact that
I could possibly have been living and
sleeping with a
pedophile after all my history and
everything else as well and um so I kind
of go okay right I and he he sets it up
I me talking to the actual victim in the
case of his and the real one and it was
the real one and um she she spoke to me
and said no it never happened I signed
something to say you know he is working
for the intelligence Services I've been
on all these bases and and things like
that you know I've known him most of my
life um you know so sort of like he's a
he's a good guy um etc etc and she by
this time was um 18 or something so um
can I can I
ask was she really deeply in love with
him and he'd put her up to the same
thing to lie to you because I've I've
done a little bit of research into um
sex traffic us ironically there's a very
famous one on YouTube currently who has
specifically said in his website I will
retain them for decades after I've got
them in love with me and they will say
anything and I've seen girls online
who've been in video smacked around and
they will say in the in you know
publicly it was just a game I was just
doing it because it was part of a game
we used to play but you're seeing how
much pain she's in in the video so you
can you can see it but to her she's
still in that um warped frame of mind
that she is under his umbrella right so
so when you're saying this I'm
definitely getting some flashbacks to
that sort of behavior um and yeah that
is that and for you it was there a point
where almost like sunken cost fallacy
like I've invested so much into you that
I it can't not be true because that
would destroy me and it has to be true
it just everything I've done has been
what I've been doing has been real yeah
I've given you 200 plus th000 I've had
children to you I've married you I've
put invested everything into you so for
it not to be real would just crumble
everything so I I I can't not believe
you now yeah for my own mental sanity I
have to believe it's like that GL
Gambler finding that one last pound coin
you have to gamble it because you've
already lost everything yes I feel you
you know and it's it's just that kind of
and by now and now you know that by that
point it got you know [__] got real you
know because now we're talking about
sexual violence against someone you know
and yeah it was just it was all or
nothing was she believable the girl on
the phone she was I mean initially what
she did was she just said you know I'm
going to send you a statement just so
you know and you understand the whole
situation so I got the statement I read
the statement it just it verified
everything that he said right in
different language than he normally uses
and but of course he even that even that
length yeah because I did actually meet
meet with her afterwards and you know
sort of like with during the court case
I met with her and and she said you know
that she she she had been Co into doing
certain things um but she had actually
never sent me a statement she people
think [__] isn't a real thing out there
you know when when people get you know
this comes out oh what's coercion
coercion you're brainwashed yeah totally
yeah yeah and then um so the next stage
of this was on the 5th of April 2006 so
that kind of all happened around January
February so you took her word for it and
you sort of were like okay yeah but I
also I also at the same time was not
going to risk my children being taken
away so I had said you I said to them we
can't continue we cannot continue as a
couple because even if you are a hero
and you've never done any of this stuff
and you you've caught pedophile rings
and you know Etc even if you are that
hero if the social workers believe that
you are a pedophile they will take my
children away so you can't come home you
can't be here it's good that that was
there for you like you know how there's
so much logic defy um uh defying things
that you
you you got through the love and the
brainwashing that you had you still had
that I'm not going to [__] my family
over and I'm not going to give my kids
up no matter what you do so that was
still there yeah I would I would cut my
own heart out break it or anything else
to look after my children but um and
then on the 5th of April 2006 I got a
phone call and I got a phone call from a
woman and she but this he was actually
going to court that day so he was going
to court that day and he was going to be
charged um sort of with a and and plead
guilty or not to to all these different
crimes um and he' said you know my my
female lawyer will call you um and let
you know what happened so I got this
phone call and so I thought it was the
lawyer and she just said are you Mary
turn of Thompson and I said yes and she
said are you also Mrs Jordan and I said
yes and she said I'm the other Mrs
Jordan and then she said have you been
told I'm an agent and I said yes and she
said I've been told you're an agent oh
and that eight words those eight words
shattered The
Matrix you know I actually I'm I've gone
cold my whole body has gotone cold just
even saying them out loud again it just
the all the walls around me crumbled and
I saw the truth for what it was and it's
like there were no shadowy people there
were no it was all him everything and
it's like and we talked on the phone for
about 2 hours and then she said I'm
coming up and she jumped in the car and
she came straight up to Edinburgh and we
sat and we talked for 12 hours we
actually we actually went I didn't want
her in the fat to start with so I I I
got a friend um and she came and sort of
looked after the kids and she me and the
the other Mrs Jordan went up to a cafe
did you have children with her as well
no she she she had five children with
him but she she left them behind so
sorry what I meant was she had children
to him yes yeah five five okay um so and
so we went to this Cafe and as we walked
into the cafe you know sort of like
we're kind of both in shock um and the
guy at the the counter said you know can
I help you and I said I don't know we've
just both found out we married to the
same man and he said um I meant
something to drink and I and I just
turned around and said oh all right two
cups of tea and he said do you want to
share a pot
blood how did she get your phone number
to ring you what what what happened in
her life to know she apparently she'd
had it for a while um she she she' had
it in a notebook somewhere for a while
she'd been told and it was an emergency
number that she was never to call um but
because he was at court that day
something triggered in her she just
decided to phone it so what was your CT
for this this this initial thing the the
bigamy fraud firearms and not riching
his dress so okay and had something
happened to tell like had he gone down
or no he actually the court date was
delayed so he he hadn't even gone to
court they they they just they kept
postponing it uh I mean that was a 2006
he actually went to court in November
2006 oh so cuz they kept bumping it up
to the Crown Court it was it was
initially just a lower court and then it
went up to Crown Court so it just it
just kept getting delayed always happens
with them I don't know why I don't know
if it's normal because you know I've not
been involved in many other criminal
cases you know well yeah um thankfully
and this one's want to end all I guess
and you were sitting there with this
other woman who is has a family to this
man you have a family to this man what
was that conversation like would you did
you was there animosity there or was was
there was there like friendship there
immediately it was I mean certainly not
on my part that she was sort of treating
me a little bit about like the mistress
um she felt like the main one yeah she I
mean she'd been married him 10 years
younger than me so technically she was
the main one um my marriage was
basically non-existent so um Yes mine
wasn't legal in the first place so how
come because he was already married you
can't marry someone when you already
married so bigam me is you know it's
legal but it's also it meant my marriage
wasn't legalized in the first place but
to you it was the whole time and you you
signed everything done yeah yeah so it's
like but yeah but so she was actually
correct in the sense that I was
technically I wasn't you know but I
didn't she also knew that I hadn't known
any of this so you know she she was kind
of like yeah so she went around kind of
looking at things and going that's
that's his and I was going no that's
mine and she was going oh right you know
he's got something like that done our
house too you know so she went around
looking at things and and stuff and we
actually we sat down and we she she she
rang his parents and spoke to them um
and you know I recognize the voices that
people I used to speak to so you know it
was they were complicit in it all um his
parents were working on behalf of him to
keep the secret yeah oh and not just not
just about her five children and my two
children but also the nanny's two
children but the parents were also
informed by ious other people um which
we'll get to as well but um yeah I mean
this is this is it sounds like that's
the ending of the story it's really not
that's just kind of like we're getting
to the you know sort of you know it just
goes downhill from here so so this woman
is is quite naturally she's she's [__]
up about this because she's like you
know I thought I was the one and only
and now here you are she she she knew he
had affairs oh so she knew because she
she actually the nanny had a baby Baby
by him and she said well that's my
children's sibling so you can come live
with us uh Nanny could carry on being
the nany and the child would be and then
she got pregnant again by him wow so she
let the nany stay after he got her up
the dff yeah well she I think she I
don't know I mean if I'm being generous
you know it's it's you know she was
trying to think about the children
growing up in isolation without their
siblings you know sort of like so this
was a half sibling to her own children
you know the first child and it's like
oh no I you know you kind of fair play
but not many women would be like and she
can keep cleaning for us cuz she's been
cleaning quite enough thank you very
much um but no so yeah it's it's it's a
I mean it's a really complicated
situation but she did know about other
Affairs because she knew about the there
was a lady in Japan um for instance who
actually we knew of her but she's only
recently got in touch with us um so
Japan was actually true yeah but he was
only there for a few weeks he that's
that's enough for
yeah he just has a little taste of
things know stuff like that and then so
yeah he had had an affair with a girl in
Japan um there was another you know
there various things out you know so
over the over the next few
months um I I kind of I decided to go
public I decided that
a this is going to be a very long
conversation but um I'm here for
it I right I I don't I don't have any
issue talking about this but I know it's
a trigger for some people so I want to
warn people that I'm going to be talking
about something I appreciate that um I I
was sexually abused when I was a child
right now I was groomed by a friend of
the family it wasn't my wasn't any my
family but a friend of the family
groomed me played a game with me made me
feel like I was um the the sort of the
hideand-seek and find me first kind of
thing so you know the youngest to four
children getting the attention of an
adult I was groomed I participated in
his game I was sexually abused over
about 6 months right that finished when
I was about 6 years old right I tortured
myself from the age of six to the age of
26 right the Damage Done To Me finished
when I was six but I from 6 to 26 I
self-harmed I thought I was a piece of
[__] because I had participated in his
game and therefore I was as bad as a
pedophile because I didn't say no right
so because I had enjoyed that game that
made me an awful person at the age of 26
I said suddenly realized that what had
done to me stopped when I was six but
everything else had done to myself so
with that
realization I went I am never doing that
to myself again I'm never going to
punish myself from having been a victim
of a crime all right so when this
happened I went I'm not doing that again
yeah I got all that life experience of
knowing this was not my fault I might
have been naive you know sort of like
you you were saying like you know you
you this could happen to anyone this
would never happen to me again because I
now know everything that there is to
know about psychopath and function so I
would never get caught again and that's
why I try and educate people because
hopefully it will stop them from being
caught you know so if I knew now what I
knew if I knew then what I knew now it
would never have happened of course but
then I'd never had my wonderful children
so um but yeah so I I I so you gain
strength from something which is
horrific like the worst thing want to go
through and you pulled from that and now
it was okay now I'm going to deal with
you differently yeah yeah I like that so
instead of and it's a very similar thing
being groomed by a psychopath into a
relationship adult it's exactly the same
so I kind of like came out of that
literally that conversation with the
other wife and I texted him in the
morning and just said done you know she
she'd said don't don't let him know that
he that you know and we've met because I
want to get the kids away from him uh
and uh so I I kind of said yeah okay
fine um so I didn't say you know I've
just we've talked Etc what I said is
just I'm done that's it you know we're
over uh I thought dumping over her text
was appropriate um not usually but you
know in this case I thought it was he's
not worth anything right how did you
react um oh first of all it was um anger
and then pleading and then you know sort
of like can I call you and then tried to
call me and I wouldn't reply and you
know s of like why are you doing this
and it went back and forth like that
within the time it took her to get down
there um was it hard to keep strong
because I'm just I'm just want to put
the scenario there because I would
assume like you've wanted a certain
level of attention and craving from and
now all of a sudden you're showing
strength out of nowhere and he is trying
to do you know what I mean so that 20
years yeah that 20 years from 6 to 26 of
of resilience and never going there
again that literally from from when I
spoke to her it was done there was no
going back it wasn't like I was sitting
there going oh but I love him or
anything else it was broken there was I
had jumped that Grand Canyon and there
was no going back it it wasn't any kind
of like you know knowing the truth and
knowing that that everything that
happened had been him doing it to me you
know every single thing he'd done the
very moment he'd contacted me that email
he crafted that he sent to me on that
online dating thing said that he was
infertile as a child from bad about
months he Li to me from the very very
first words he'd sent me and his wife
and his Nanny were both in the house and
both pregnant when he wrote that email
to me so it wasn't like he was mistaken
or anything he had deliberately set me
up from the very very beginning so there
wasn't anything that might kind of went
in my head oh but maybe actually my
sister once said to me she'll hate me
for the sess but my sister once said to
me you know so like after the whole
thing she
said you think you might ever take him
back and I was just going not on your
life never not happening no and it's
just because she is a romantic and but
it's also very hard like I've you know
we've all seen those toxic relationships
where one of them is a real like
especially one of them in particular is
the really bad one and you're like but
she always or he always takes her back
or what you know what I mean you kind of
I can understand the questioning but
that's addiction thank God you had this
yeah addiction and that's kind of what I
was referring to with um the women who
get obsessed by these toxic men a lot of
the time because it's that hot and cold
thing you get addicted to the endorphins
going not knowing what the [__] coming
next but it's so good that you did have
that strength um so so now the the word
is out and and and it's it's gaining
momentum and you're um but he he he he's
on the way back and he doesn't know that
she knows as well so how does that
unfold well as soon as she arrived back
you know she told him so um so then
suddenly it's all I Now understand how
could you do that you know that you know
this is situation you know there's more
to this you know there's more to to this
and meets the ey you know sort of like
you don't understand she's all about
money there's this that and the other I
mean it's all all just lay upon layer of
other [__] and it's just like it
just wasn't happening it was just like
and I just constantly and for a while I
was really nervous that he would just
pitch up on the doorstep because I was
worried as that eye contact as that you
know and I was worried that he might be
able to suck me back in that way but did
you ever fear Him physically as in he
may do something to hurt you no not
really um no I lived in fear of other
people not not him
you know but um the the idea that he
might turn off on the doorstep made me
very very uncomfortable and then I
realized that all his texts were all
about let me come and see you let me do
this let me come you know I want to come
and talk to you you know we need to talk
face to face Etc and I realized that he
was constantly trying to say and I
realized that actually what's happening
is if I said yes if I said yes to seeing
him face to face then he was already
halfway there because there's always
there's something that I will accept
that he will say that will solve the the
situation and it's like so that's the
equation in his head and he's been using
that same equation over and over again
but the psychology of it really works
because it's like if you say you know if
he turns up on the door I can slam it in
his face if he says will you agree to
meet me and I agree then I'm already
saying there's something that he can say
that I will listen to so I just kept
saying no no not going to meet you not
going to meet you and it's like you know
it just it he carried on from April to
September um my mother died in that
period so my mother was terminally ill
um just after I found out about him my
mother then was diagnosed time a yell
and she actually died on the 15th of
August so the whole process as well of
that going on what a life you were
having and it was it was it was an
interesting year um no it really must
have been hell man I feel for you yeah
seriously but uh um and then you know
sort like all the way through that and
he was like can I come and comfort you
with your mother diet I mean everything
he was even using that evening that so I
need to see the kids all the time and
the stuff that and I was just like no no
just kept saying no and then you know he
got out in bail for what he' done and I
actually s of like I suddenly had this
kind of brain wave and I as well was
talking to the police um and giving them
um explanations of what was going on and
and and stuff like that and I eventually
turn around to police at one point and
said do you know where he is and they
said we can't tell you where he is and I
said no I don't want to know where he is
I want to know if you know where he is
and they said well you know so we we
don't need to know where he is he's out
in bail as long as he turns up to court
and I said yes you do he is a convicted
sex offender he has to register his
address under the Sex Offenders Act do
you know where he is and they went good
point how the hell are they are you
telling them like hey that's a good hey
tell you she's on to something yeah
maybe you should check that up so they
went they went to the hostel that he
said he was staying at and he wasn't
there so they they tracked him down they
arrested him and put him in jail and he
was in jail until till the court after
that and that's when he stopped trying
cuz that's when he kind of like I don't
even know if he knew it was me that had
done that if he doesn't he probably does
now but um you know so like and that was
that was that the end of it and then I
wrote a victim impact statement that
went to the judge by this stage I'd done
a lot of research into I realized that
he was a sociopath psychopath psychopath
now I realized but at the time I called
it sociopath um now I can tell you what
the difference is um but and you know so
I wrote to the theud and said this is
how all the crimes tie together because
he was going to say he'd married me
because I was pregnant that you know
he'd he'd you know that the yes he
played around but he was just a bit of a
bad lad you know said and that's you
know the fiance had found out and that's
why she'd said that he took you know
sort of like she gave him permission but
then took the permission away that you
know that he's American so he didn't
realize that taser was illegal you know
he was going to just belittle all these
things and sort of separate them off so
they seemed like in consequential don't
play Everything so I I wrote to the
judge and I told him everything and I
just said this is what the scenario is
um and I also got
really um slightly hyper fixated on
things so I end up going through the
phone bills and ringing people up that
you know because I was paying the bill
so I I had his phone bill and I came
across so five
fiances um you know various businessmen
um various landlords Etc um all of which
he had conned um you know so of I came
across his um son in America um so he
has a son that's now 40 um uh came
across so we know 10 children at a time
um you know sort of like when I went to
it just it just goes on and on and on
you play investigator because I mean I'm
assuming the police wouldn't have gone
into this level of of depth that cuz you
had motivation you wanted to really nail
him to the wall at this point and and
also make keep I wanted to understand I
wanted I wanted to get the bigger
picture I wanted to be able if you can
see the bigger picture it means you're
standing away from it all right so when
you're in a relationship particular this
toxic one if you're in it f you can't
see it you can always see your friends
toxic relationships but you can't see
your own right that is great you know
what I mean so it's like if you can step
out of it and actually see the bigger
picture then then you you've got that
perspective and you understand what's
happening and that's what I wanted I
wanted to be able to by talking to all
the I wasn't even thinking about writing
a book then I was just thinking I need
to know I need to have this information
as much as I can as quick as I can and
you know 10 fiance is I mean I are we
saying that the money he was taking from
you he was using in his other situations
with other people and using it to set up
other victims yeah I know that the um
the otherwise children went to private
school right so in that sense this web
which is kind of similar to the the
Tinder swindler story is you're pulling
from this one you're spending it on that
one is is kind of what he was doing in
that scenario then he might he might
have been giving money to his parents as
well you know he might paying them for
the bloody backup story it might have
been gambling they might have been doing
anything I mean doesn't it it's just a
measure of control it's not really you
know I don't think that the other wife
was living lap of luxury but they were I
mean lots of kids so I mean not just her
own the nannies and you know so that
there was there was a lot of things
going on and they moved every year
because you know although they lived in
these big houses he didn't pay the rent
and so like he would pay the deposit and
and then the the rent wouldn't get paid
and so months would go by the landlord
and constant excuses oh it's coming it's
coming there's something wrong with this
something wrong with that you know um
and then eventually the landlord would
take him to court and then the day
before the court date he would ring up
and say my wife's just broken a leg um
and so the court would cancel it and
reschedule another month later and then
when he did go to court he would go
here's a check and he give it to the
landlords and the judge would go done
deal um and then you know so that when
of course the check would bounce and
then the landlord has to go take them
back to court again so it would take
about a year to evict them so that
family were moving every year into a new
property and she she fully believed that
he was working for
MI6 so you know she she had connections
with American intelligence so he
couldn't be a CIA so he had to say he
was MI6 to her so she she fully believed
all this stuff was going on was very
shady deals and stuff like that her
story is just like a whole another level
to mine yeah it's 10 years on top of
that so God only knows what else has
been going on she didn't have any money
so I mean the things it's not my story
to tell but she you know the things he
did to her make my my story look like a
fairy tale so um and and so you're
digging you're doing your digging you're
coming up with more babies more fiance
10 more fiance I mean your your mind is
obviously becoming more and more blown
um but you want to get this story and
what was the purpose of the story this
Point are you going to try and use this
in his court case or no when when on my
day before my mom died um I saw her in a
hospital and she said you have to write
this down she said if this has happened
to you it's happened to someone else and
she said you know it just if if nobody
else is standing up and talking about it
you have to be the one that does um so
she said you know i' I'd walked into a
Bookshop and I said you know I've just
found out my husband is a bigist Aon man
who's actively impregnating women to
written off money and I want to read a
book about it and they the guy behind
the counter just
went so it's like not been done there
isn't a book like that so um I after my
mom died I I went to the ENA Book
Festival and did some workshops and then
I I went into a life writing Workshop um
and before the publisher and the agent
got off the stage or just as they were
getting off the stage I leapt out my
seat and ran down and talked to them and
I said this is what's happened and they
both gave me their card and that's now
my agent in my first publisher um so I
never had to go and Pitch it to anyone
because no no big Miss wife had ever
written a story about it before because
everybody had always been so humiliated
and so ashamed of what had happened to
them that they wouldn't want to stand up
and talk about it and what made me
different is I know I have nothing to be
ashamed of I had that 20 years of Shame
and I knew there was there was nothing
that I'd done other than try to be the
best wife I could be and the best mother
I could be and i' had been naive um but
I think pretty much anyone who listens
to me knows that I'm not stupid
and I knew I wasn't stupid and it's like
if it can happen to me it could happen
to others so yeah so writing writing my
first book The bigamist was just like it
was just pure cathis you know it was
just three months of this is what I
found this is what happened and this is
what I found out so at this point
nothing had sorry he' the the cour case
had been and gone and you knew of other
other victims but you didn't know the
full scale of it and that came with the
book research and the more you dug so
we're now getting to see the bigger
picture now
and how how big is the picture when
you're looking at it in terms of victims
in terms of money in terms of people and
you kind you've met some of these people
so yeah so that the the at the time I
knew five fiance's two wives I knew have
uh a couple of people in America before
he came over to the UK with his uh wife
um and so there were there were 10
children um and about uh about 10 10
eight or nine women um and there were
also the landlords and there was also a
couple of businessmen that he ripped off
for hundreds of thousands of pounds yeah
um not to mention the the other the um
software company and stuff um the
company the company in
Manchester and that he was announced
being in the times um they actually once
once the book came out once the bigamist
came out and I went public with a story
so many people came out the redw and
that company that that that he'd been
announced as having having worked for in
the times um they had gone busted
because of him wow because he he totally
destroyed their company uh and not least
because he actually they gave him a
company car and he drove it to the
airport and left it in the short-term
parking um and they I think it I think
they found it like 12 years later know
they didn't know where it was and they
got the the you know the company
actually got a bill for the for the 12
years of parking shortterm parking that
it was worth I mean the bill was worth
more than the car were you speaking to
any of these fiancees directly yeah what
was what were those conversations like
and CU you're kind of at times the
bearer of the bad news right and that's
not easy to do you know it was
incredible I mean talking to for
instance the fiance that brought the
charges against him for the fraud that
set everything in motion in fact because
she set up the police sting so I
actually saw her as my My Savior and and
we're we're still in contact UM in fact
it's jumping ahead slightly but um you
have to shorten this story somehow don't
you because I went public with the book
and so many more people came out of the
woodwork and then when he was he went to
jail he was convicted five years to two
and a half he was deported straight from
jail back to the USA in in March 20 no
uh 2nd of March
2009 um and he immediately started doing
it again so there's now all the new
victims from America so within within 9
months I was contacted by three new
people one of which was pregnant um and
you know sort of like two others who had
been ripped off of money um then he went
quiet for a few years changed his name
did some other things and I got contact
by a whole new raft of people uh
including one lady called Michelle Lewis
and she's amazing she's like my we're
like two pillars either side of the
Atlantic that kind of have kept this
this community of women going so we
created a Facebook group wow and we had
21 victims on it at one point and you
know sort of like and and it's got a lot
less now but you know we were just this
community of people who came together
just talking about this same man and
knowing and that catharsis of knowing
that it's not just me he didn't do this
to me because of who I am he did this to
me because of who he is and it's like a
cat playing with a mouse it's nothing to
do with the mouse it's just the Cat's
game you know and it's it's not personal
and actually finding out that he was a
different person with each of us as well
you know and all that kind of jazz we
actually we actually mapped out where he
was when which is how I know he wasn't
he wasn't in Edinburgh when you know he
said come and pick pick me up I know he
was in Oxford because I know he was
there then you know sort of like it's
how I know you know what he was doing to
his feet you know and there's I mean
there's so much more to this um you know
sort of like different aspects we can
talk about but you know the the behavior
we were able to map and see what what he
was doing and when and how and you know
how he was overlapping with things did
any of the women report anything like
physically abusive or any more of the
issues with children or whatever
anything like that there was there was
no other issues of any kind of um sexual
assault on children certainly I think he
learned his lesson with that one um I
think he realized that was the biggest
mistake he ever made um logically um
because that's that's followed him and
that's that's that's a that's a one he
can't excuse really um but uh yeah
certainly there there was one one
relationship you had where you had
someone up by the throat against the
wall kind of thing uh and would have
explosive anger um and stuff but again I
think it's just because that's what
worked and that relationship
intimidation was something that actually
worked in that relationship and how much
money did he train from these other
women do you think I think I was the one
that that the lost the most um I mean it
wasn't just the the £98,000 um once this
the dust cleared it also turned out he'd
taking credit cards out in my name so I
was actually left with £56,000 worth of
debt that was fun um cuz that was that I
mean for for months afterwards I was
getting phone calls from people going
you need to pay this credit card debt
and I was going as I told you yesterday
you know this is my you know taking out
my husband took it out in my name in my
name I had no you know husbands can do
that I think we taking out One credit
card and he like forged the others are
you are you still liable for that even
though it's a crime that he did no I
sold I sold my story to the Daily Mail
um in you know sort of 2006 when it was
all going to court and they gave me
8,000 and we put that into a pot and
said to all these people you can take
pennies in the pound or you can wait
years you can get5 pounds a week kind of
thing or5 p a month and you know so they
took it so I was actually out of debt
within six months thank God but yeah so
it was it was great relief that but you
know it was yeah one of the hardest
things I had to do was go to my mom and
say you have to cut me out the whe
cuz it's like otherwise it's just going
to all go to his
debts and that was tough but um that
brutal like right in there but like you
know thank I mean look thank God you uh
you navigated the situation really well
for all uh you've talked about you know
trying not to feel shame for what you
went through uh the way you handled it
when you had your eyes opened you you
investigated you were Brave uh smart
you connected the dots you brought other
people in you made it as hard for him to
do this again as humanly possible so you
got to take credit in that yeah but it's
not I want to make something quite clear
none of that was done out of Revenge
right I don't I don't hate him I don't
even actually dislike him I know this
sounds really weird right I I actually
feel nothing for him but what I do want
to do is try and protect future victims
you know I I want to educate people so
that they understand so they don't fall
for the same thing I did you know people
think that the red flag in a
relationship is when they ask you for
money right so you got to be watching
you know they ask you for money or
that's you're already too late by the
time they ask you for money you are
already hooked they've set you up for
that moment yeah the groundw work's been
done yeah so it's like the the in
understanding that the red flags are
actually the the love bombing that
actually when you're taking you slightly
off balance when they're slightly
there's all sorts of techniques and I
actually talk about them in the book but
there's all sorts of techniques they use
where you feeling that you feel they're
building you up and actually what
they're doing is knocking you down
they're knocking your self-confidence
constantly so you feel that the only
person who actually has your back is
them the feeling of being yo-yoed is for
sure like I you can meet a guy and he
can quote unquote like I know the love
bombing is a specific technique but he
can be really nice to you over the top
nice to you but if he's always that and
he's never you you AR getting the yo-yo
then you're probably fine like he's just
being a good guy but like you say it's
this this feeling of the state that he
keeps you in of not knowing what the
hell's coming next is is where you don't
know where you stand um but um was there
any other shocking things that happened
throughout these investigative uh things
that you did I don't know so
many I think one that I think you've got
quite a lot of male listeners so they
might like this one is that um uh one of
his Partners actually didn't want to
have any more children so she said she'd
have her tubes tied um and he said no
darling that's that's too invasive you
know I'll go and have a vasectomy
instead so he went away and came back
with what looked like two cigarette
Burns either side of his
testies and strangely enough she got
pregnant again [__] hell this guy
burned his own balls for a story twice
wow the Psychopaths don't have any
empathy for themselves any more than
they do anybody else right so main
difference I think between a psychopath
and a narcissist is a psychopath doesn't
care about anybody including including
themselves whereas a narcissist doesn't
care about anyone except themselves um
and uh yeah he even though he felt that
pain the first time um he doesn't care
that his future self is going to pain
feel that pain again in a few
seconds so they they you know they just
don't care about the future it's like
you might you might go out tonight and
and and have a drink but you've got
something to do tomorrow so you won't
because you don't want to have the
hangover you know so you care about your
future self right they don't M they
don't care it's like that not for them
why would they do anything you know for
this future it's so like shock likee
isn't it
predatory um that's why they don't mind
kind of going it's not that they don't
mind but they expect to go to jail at
some point you know they know they're
going to get caught eventually because
they're going to keep pushing the
boundaries until they do like like the
the Ted bundies of this world like they
they will continue to do what they do um
no matter what happens and and do you
know where he is now I do well actually
this this year has been amazing because
it's like I actually got to go to
America with filming the documentary oh
wow so my daughter and I flew to to
America and we met some of the other
victims so I mean I've been talking to
some of these people for like 14 years
um and you know but we've and we've
talked online and we we're we're really
close I mean talking them through new
relationships you know we understand the
the issues that that each other has
explain this yeah and so they don't have
to kind of talk about the background
it's like oh my God I'm going on a date
you know they've done this am I being
oversensitive you know um and you know
so we we've supported each other you
know people have gone off and got
married and had children and and were
still supporting each other you know um
and know so to be able to go over to
America and meet them and um but we also
awesomely the production actually helped
get a private detective um because one
thing I've always said is like doesn't
matter where he is he will be committing
some crime um so so true yeah and uh and
we were
successful so and uh so yes he is
currently currently residing in jail
weai in trial again wow so before this
time uh I larney um Czech
fraud um you know variety of things as
usual know but uh yeah and so I mean it
was just it was amazing and it was just
you know just meeting meeting Michelle
and you know some of the EV Evelyn and
some of the others there was out of the
21 victims I know only five wanted to be
on the documentary series so you know
you can't blame I understand but um yeah
it was It was kind of cool it was kind
of cool that the five of us actually did
sit on speak but yeah it's a it's a
Sisterhood I don't know how to describe
it it's just the you know we all there's
none of us sitting there going you were
with my man in our I mean it's just like
you know we're all we're all sort of
really supportive each other so it's an
incredible feeling to actually be able
to stand and actually hug them and now
your goal coming out of this is to
better educate other people so that they
can spot these red flags uh early enough
so that you don't get into that
situation where these are they're then
asking you for money and all of that so
so how has that been for you it's
amazing I'm I'm part of a I'm actually
on the uh Board of advisers for an
organization called psychopathy is which
is an international organization of
neuroscientists and specialists in in
psychopathy I don't know why I'm you
know like just I I I've got no
qualifications in it but just the you
qualifi but um and one of the things
that that you know we really need to do
I mean a society has to do is that 1% of
society full-blown Psychopaths 4% of
CEOs 25% of the prison population these
are all s statistics you can think of
right but you're not allowed to diagnose
somebody as a psychopath until they're
18 all right by which time they're
cooked right just because somebody has
lack of empathy guilt and remor does not
make them a bad person all right it
makes them have the capacity to do
anything
right we need to be able to diagnose
people children as with psychopathy
because the there are a lot of them and
they cause the the damage they do to
society will Jordan has done so much
damage millions and millions of pounds
worth of financial damage but also he is
creating people people have committed
suicide over what he's done um people
have yes and and it's not just the
partners and the children it's the it's
the stepchildren that I mean I had a I
had a daughter he get single mothers you
know so it's the sisters the brothers
the moms the dads that it goes off like
a bomb in a community this person so 1%
of the society are not affecting the
just 100 people in their lifetime it's a
ripple effect yeah is they're affecting
thousands so the chances of you not
having met a psychopath in your lifetime
are pretty much zero all right and they
affect people they they they really do
damage in society so if we can actually
Target you know children and say okay
this this child is show sewing and and
the first sign of psychopathy is
fearlessness because they don't care
about the consequences so the the
children who are completely Fearless
that the ones that you're actually going
to go okay that is a a red flag but if
we can say that okay rather than saying
you know little Johnny you know if you
do that you're going to hurt mommy's
feelings because that means nothing to
them or you're going to be in trouble
later on you know if we can actually cut
find a different way of bringing those
children up so they become you know have
a good moral code and actually
understand their condition then they
won't necessarily become monsters in
society and go and going back to you
said someone had committed suicide uh
who who was that it was uh one of the
nannies wow so
yeah and by the way now I know 14
children by eight different women with
the with this the new children being
born in America as well since his
release um and you know so the yeah 21
victims 14 children whole load of
landlords and business people as well um
you know so there sort of like within
within that sort of community I mean I
know of you know 50 odd people who who
he has affected their lives
dramatically you know it's like that's
that's just and that's the tip of the
iceberg I reckon there's probably more
likely to be about 40 children because
those are just the ones that have come
forward since I went public have come
forward and said actually me too yeah I
mean how many people who was he
operating under a different name with
who'll never ever even hear of this yeah
or don't or don't you know they don't
know what happened to him or or don't
even you know or know and don't want to
be connected they don't want to know any
anyone else to know I mean as I say the
girl in Japan that was
1997 um she she saw uh an NBC dat line
program that me and Michelle did years
ago um that's still doing the rounds and
she saw it I think in Germany or
something um and uh she she got in touch
and said oh my gosh you know I knew knew
I would see a thing about him one day
you know and gave us you know pieces of
information that we didn't have before
as well about that that time period um
so yeah she's part of the group now I
think it's good that you uh said that
you don't hate him and that he doesn't
have that hold on you and you've just
let go because that you know while
you're still living with that feeling
you can never really be free of it right
so that's great that you've got it that
point mentally yeah I don't I don't even
wish him I don't wish him harm or
anything else I I'm glad he's Behind
Bars because I mean we've just literally
freed another victim you know so that
that was that was somebody that that was
in America that he was still abusing for
wonderful better will um so you know she
now at least can get on with her life
and try and sort of repair things so
it's not about enacting revenge on him
and you know I want him in jail because
I'm vindictive or anything but doing
that means that she's now free doing
that means that all those people in
America can rest easy I can rest easy
because he's not allowed back in the
country you know but the people in
America like Michelle you know she's got
she can he could be around any corner
you know so but she can rest easy whilst
she's in jail knowing that that she's
not going to bump into him so it's it's
more about sort of as I say protecting
the victims than it is about any
vindictiveness against him he used to be
he used to be a really really good con
man he's not he's not so good anymore
he's getting older and he's getting less
desirable as well right part of the
charm is you know a certain look a
certain attitude and yeah but he's also
I mean he's he's not just getting older
but he's actually I think it's made I've
made it quite hard for him
yeah yeah you definitely have I wanted
one last mention of your book if anyone
wants to purchase it I'm going to put
the link in the description below Mary
turn at Thompson the psychopath a true
story uh if you want to know in even
more detail uh all those specific
memories are in there and obviously the
documentary is going to be on what
channel it's on ITV x uh and SCV player
and it's called the other Mrs Jordan
catching the ultimate con man very good
well I'll definitely check that out as
well uh in full uh ladies and gentlemen
Mary on the true Jordy podcast thank you
very much appreciate it thank you well
[Music]
done